If I were to come over to your
place and say, name this
molecule, the first thing you
would do is you'd say, well,
look, we have a double
bond, So we're
dealing with an alkene.
We have four carbons in
the longest chain.
There's actually
one chain here.
So it's one, two, three,
four carbons.
So the prefix will be but-, and
regardless of which end
you count from, the double bond
starts at the number two
carbon, so this is but-2-ene.
I'd say, well, that's very
good, and that is correct
based on everything
we've learned.
But what about what about
this molecule?
What about the molecule
that looks like this?
And you'd go through
the same process.
You'd say it has
a double bond.
It's an alkene.
Our longest chain has
four carbons:
one, two, three, four.
Regardless of which end you
start counting from, the
double bond starts at the number
two carbon: one, two,
three, four.
So once again, you say, hey,
Sal, that's also but-2-ene.
And I'd point out that these
are each fundamentally
different molecules.
And the reason why they're
fundamentally different
molecules is because this double
bond can't rotate.
It's got that pi bond there
for that second bond that
keeps this carbon-carbon
bond rigid.
So it's not like the molecule
can switch configurations
between this-- it's not like
it can switch conformations
between this and that.
It cannot rotate around this
double bond, so these are
different molecules.
These are different molecules
that will behave different
chemically.
And because they behave
different, we have to have
different names for them.
Now, there's two different
naming conventions.
One is the simpler naming
convention, and it works when
we have one functional group on
each of the carbons in the
double bond.
And then in the next two videos,
we'll talk about the
slightly more advanced naming
scheme that will work when we
have more than one
functional group.
So the first way to name
it is if you have
your functional groups.
So let me circle the
functional groups.
So in this top one, our
functional groups are on
opposite sides.
They're apart.
They're on opposite sides of the
carbon-carbon double bond.
This is on the top, This
is on the bottom.
In this molecule right here, our
functional groups are on
the same side.
So when our functional groups
are on different sides, we
could call it trans.
We could call it trans,
literally, I believe, Latin
for, apart, or Latin
for opposite.
I'm not a Latin scholar,
so forgive me.
But the functional groups
are apart, so we call it
trans-but-2-ene.
The other convention to use
comes from the German forepart
and there we call it entgegen.
And instead of writing out
entgegen, we write E in
parentheses.
So we would call them-- let me
just use different colors
since this molecule
down here is blue.
So we would call this
(E)-but-2-ene.
These mean the same thing.
But this is now kind of the
standard convention.
We'll see this notation where
you use entgegen, or (E), is
actually more powerful.
It can extend to when we have
more than one functional group
on each carbon.
Let me just make it clear that
the (E) stands for entgegen,
which is German for apart, or
at least I believe it is.
I can't speak German so I'll
just have to take people's
words for it.
Now, in this situation where our
functional groups are on
the same side, you could call
this cis-but-2-ene.
Cis, I believe, comes from the
Latin for together, or you
could call it (Z)-but-2-ene.
And you could imagine
this (Z) comes from
the German for together.
And it stands for zusammen,
which is German for together.
And that's all you have to do.
And in the next few videos,
we'll do a bunch of examples
here so we can really figure out
whether to label something
with either an (E) or a (Z).
But I wanted expose you to the
cis- and trans- naming scheme,
because that's sometimes used
for simpler molecules where
you only have one functional
group on each side.
But I want you to realize that
they're really trying to make
the same differentiation.
They're really just trying to
decide whether the functional
groups on one side of a double
bond and on the other side of
a double bond, whether they're
on the same side, cis-, or
(Z), or zusammen, or on
different sides, trans- or
(E), or entgegen.